i love this because we just uh met
that love
uh as a grown-up for the first for the
first time
and this is awesome because he's getting
on his horse
then we're going to play like a bit of
the song
and then i'm going to bust a rewind
i like that yeah yeah i like how you cut
off the netflix uh thing you just
chopped them off right when they were
like
walking through the stage and you just
like that's like a mason puffy boat like
when mason wanted them is it puppy
was in the camera and mace just pushed
him out the way and it was just like
yeah
let me get that camera
and here and it is where it begins
because because like look right we we
have kid cut
right
and it's so distinct but over a title
sequence which is my homage to paul
newman and and robert redford in the
sting that's one that like
uh titles old school type sequence where
they show what um character
what actor is playing what character
that doesn't happen happens at the end
of
the film but to do that at the beginning
of cuddy's voice
avalon be dead like it's
like hair standing up on the back of my
neck when i'm first seeing this
yeah yeah did it hit you when you first
started coming
yeah oh man it was it was it was crazy
because like you know just when you
you know cause you explain it to me and
you're so
expressive and
detailed and i got it but like when you
see it it's like
holy [ __ ] man it's like mad happy
yeah yeah this
the trudy smith is one of my favorite
images and coffee
coffee we've had eyes and then you have
like rufus [ __ ] i love guppy's eyes
her eyes man just amazing then they show
the law
while the other that's a great shot by
the way he was amazing he's amazing
over like over like whole giving us the
giving off us the bars like i always
feel like what would it be like watching
this
if
i wasn't james if i was nothing to i'm a
heart attack i'd be like
i'm at the game
yeah amazing man
and the title sequence j remember we
used the real art that we had for the
campaign
yeah yeah um now when we first saw when
we first saw that uh
change it up on us we were like wait a
minute where's the where's the original
article yeah
this don't change things to just be
changed you know like that we love that
like we want to see that that was iconic
and amazing yeah
we use the end and we put it we use the
art that they gave us for the actual
campaign in the opening title sequence
the art was so dope so everything it's
just uh it's just uniform wicked yeah so
where where did you joe james where did
you get the idea the concept to do the
the intro like this
i had like we had originally an intro
with matt love riding he was just riding
across the plains of the of the desert
and tendon
who who turned on again at netflix who
you know scott
um he was like that's a lot of real
estate that's a lot of real estate to to
um
where we could use story we could tell a
story
in there it's a lot of real estate to
waste
like a minute and a half of credits of
just riding i was like
then if we put the blah blah blah scott
mescalli as
jay-z as
james 7 as the bullets you know um it
would just be a brilliant uh you know
brilliant
thing and a brilliant statement i'll
probably do that for all my films right
uh but we didn't have the images
and then me jay and jl were just like
james lester we were just like well
let's use damages
that we have they're already amazing
it's just like a whole organic a whole
organic um yeah the whole beginning was
different remember when we first talked
about the beginning well you explained
the beginning to me it was like this
whole shot like no and he touches the
bread and there's no and then like
there's a bunch of no's and then it goes
into the house and then you see this
child when someone walks in and he's
like no
yeah but i you know just very fortunate
but like feel very blessed to be a part
of one of those sort of uh openings like
we all we all discuss openings you
always discuss how when spike leave uh
yeah
now yeah yeah
mobile blues fight these openings for
mobile blues like made me go okay i'm
gonna do film forever
right when the atlas comes on on the
screen you see the atlas from universal
and the universal logo comes around as
soon as you see the u
you hear flavor flames voice u n i v e r
s a l universal your spike kick the
movie g flavor flame we've done it again
what after he gave us public enemy yeah
yes
publication we do the right thing he
comes back with a jazz movie
and plus just a little hint of public
enemy at the beginning already that was
the first time i ever saw a logo flipped
so for the opening credits oh it's just
an important thing back in the days they
had um was a saw bass he used to do all
the um opening crazy opening credits
uh uh like anatomy of a murder and all
of these amazing films opening credits
to me mean a lot a lot of filmmakers
don't like opening credits don't like
title sequences they want start with a
movie go straight and you get the talent
sequence at the end but i love the great
title sequence nothing better than
sitting down to watch a movie and a
title sequence happens and it tells me
to celebrate
what i'm about to
um see the journey i'm about to embark
on i love it man i love it
thinking about that intro like even uh
in uh um the dynasty intro is like
if you're ripping your package off your
cd
like you know somebody was ripping the
package off the cd you like what i
bought
right now yeah
exactly it was that experience it was
yes i was there
that's right
like creating those moments because
we're fans of those moments like you
know with fandom you know
so we're always trying to um accomplish
those moments so like to me i feel like
you know
humbly and respectfully but godly that
we created one of those moments you know
so no part of those moments it's great
that you don't want to fast forward you
don't want to skip intro you know what i
mean
that's right
into this thing okay so
this scene
is crazy like
it's the it's the reveal of the entire
movie it's the reason we're all here
right
but what was crazy is we didn't know
how there was always contention because
i couldn't have nat love shoot rufus
buck
first he couldn't shoot him first
every great rivalry has a conversation
pick him up i said rufus back net love
has to hear rufus buck and i remember
going back and forth with um uh our
other producer partner james last time
he was like you're shooting straight
away again we were arguing about this
for
ages not that rufus buck should talk
um to talk but
why wouldn't that love not just kill
this man immediately
and
and then
i was writing and i was like
i have no more gas in the tech let me
call
sean carter aka iceberg slim aka
h to the ism
what's cracking
and i said and i said hey man
why
he can't shoot him in the back he can't
get he can't kill him he can't kill him
and i explained it and jay was like
wrath or me see
because you've never been in this
situation
here's what would happen
he won't
that love
won't shoot a man in the back
he won't
he'll be you know jay's voice i call it
aspiration you have to kind of climb to
get to that
that love would be like pick up your
guns and turn around ruthless bucket
just talk
break it down jake break talk on that
please
[Laughter]
um yeah just the idea of you know he's a
he's a he's a principal man
right he's he's willing to die and he's
going to the ends of earth and he's
willing to be
locked up or whatever for his family
he's he's fighting to uh avenge his
family so he has morals and you know
even when doing bad you do right
and certain things he wouldn't do
so you walk in on a man and he's got his
back turned
you're not gonna just you're not going
to just shoot him because that's not his
character
um
you know there's there's a lot of uh
complexities in his characters right on
the surface
like he's the first person ever but what
he's trying to do is
he knows
that the emancipation proclamation
whatever they call that when they went
out west and took all these people home
that already existed and already lived
there
but they called it something you know
the louisiana purchase all these
beautiful marketing names for just like
we coming to take your [ __ ]
and he knew that that revolution was
coming and he was trying to prepare the
town
and there were people in the meal
progress right he wouldn't understand
where he was going with it so he had to
take hard measures so here you see this
hard man who take these hard stances but
he has principle in what he's doing
it's just that
his circumstances dictated that his life
ain't go the way of society or the way
we would like to see it you know his mom
got killed early so he he never had a
chance he never had a chance to really
be the person he could have been um yeah
you know who built all the railroads uh
rockefeller which one of them did the
rep you know the you know
all the men the the railroads and the
oil and all he could have been one of
those guys who
were part of building this this this
this nation that's who he was
and um
just so these circumstances happen so
you got these two really principal
characters and here's the face off
you don't know why i did this to you
yeah
the brothers
yeah all right this is why i did this
this man killed my mom and moved on to a
new family and you're the result of this
you're the result of i want you to feel
all the pain that i felt
it ain't enough for me to kill you as a
nine-year-old ten-year-old boy that
ain't enough for me that ain't enough
satisfaction
you know talk about sibling rivalry
right this takes it to a whole other
psycho place right he's like
i want you to feel everything that i
felt i want you to feel the loss that i
felt i want you to feel the hate and the
anger that i felt inside your body for
the for your whole entire life and then
when you find this man which is me rufus
but when you find this man
you gotta kill him
and he's your brother
you took it one step further than me
actually cause i didn't kill my brother
[Laughter]
nat love and rufus buck to share the
frame oh that was a beautiful choice of
james by the way yeah beautiful ever
until until and when you that long shot
i do is the only time you see the back
roof is back and i zoom right down
redwood all the way to um to net love on
this force to show how distant they are
they do not share the frame until rufus
buck says the words
and the sun
then he walks into a two shot that's the
first time you see um them together in
the same in the same frame right
and if you notice i do i don't employ
the use of handheld
cameras
through the entire film really they're
too anticipatory and you can always okay
it's shaky time shake your camera time
it's going to be a fight
really the only time i i did hand out
one of the only times in the movie is in
this i have steadicam on that love and
rufus but it's set the frame is set when
he's sitting now the whole time every
time my own rules was [ __ ] he's static
i do steadicam on that love and when he
his word and the son
then i go handheld so matt loves whole
world his whole equally equilibrium is
imbalance
and rufus buck who is in control of the
entire scene
is just static he has all the
information that he's imparting on um on
that love
and nat love becomes static after this
shot now we're looking at that love and
he's static right
he's static he has for all intents and
purposes become what he's killed is the
devil dead
i don't think so
i don't know
what have i what i've done you keep what
you kill you become what you you become
what you kill and and just to show the
control of of
um
rufus buck with all that information
putting it on that not to threaten him
but for that love to finish the job as
it were
become uh
me sins of the father darken the
doorstep
i became you i became you
the the whole thing like i've waited for
this thing yeah all right and then this
day but it's not and then it doesn't
happen the way i played it out right he
thought that
i hate this man
you know at the end he's pulling at the
end he's closing his eyes because now he
understands he feels for him like
you're me
like the same thing happened to you
these were situations out of both our
controls that yes that controlled our
life
and led us to this point
and led us to and led us to this point
where you have two grown men right two
grown men and in the end it's not a
shootout it's words
and tears
and what they they
their guns are they are they words the
ammunition is their tears they cry i've
never seen that in a in a movie where
the goodie and the baddie
meet at the very end and they're just
both crying both of them just crying
right what what
a statement especially
for our community for black people
you know i mean so so just
just the whole thing how how we tipped
all of the showdowns
on their head right all the showdowns
and you know in this movie we have a
whole gun fight while the gunfights
happen in the big third axe gun battle
it's the two women that throw their guns
to the side
yeah
fight
and have a fight they're the toughest
ones they're the toughest ones
they have a fist fight and and and you
know mary she either thought she killed
trudy or left her alive for a purpose
we've yet to find out on the next
that's a beautiful segway
yeah